tej a Thompson came to Britain when he
was five his parents are British
citizens and he thought he was too but
when he was 17 he committed a drugs
related offense
he says he was groomed by a gang and was
later jailed for 15 months then he got
caught up in a battle with immigration
authorities spending months at a time in
detention centres unable to work
aljazeera spoke to him shortly before he
was due to be deported to Jamaica where
he was born like um I'm stuck in a
little and ain't got no power I feel
useless and there's nothing I can do to
be honest because linear since I was 5
years old
and I don't have nobody in Jamaica to
vote he understood in the end page a and
many others like him were taken off the
passenger list after campaigners won a
legal challenge a judge ruled people in
detention centres near Heathrow Airport
should not be deported because they
hadn't had mobile phone coverage so
couldn't contact lawyers eventually the
flight to Jamaica left with fewer than
half the intended number on board these
are all foreign national offenders that
are guilty of crimes that are led to
senses of at least 12 months or more and
this includes crime such as manslaughter
in rape dealing in Class A drugs and is
absolutely right
that if you are a foreign national
offender once you have served your
sentence in the UK that we deported much
of that's disputed by charities who work
with some of the thousands of victims of
Britain's Windrush scandal because of
administrative changes in the last
decade people from former colonies who
were entitled to British citizenship
were deprived of health care and the
right to work and even deport it now
campaigners say the government's failing
to learn the right lessons people who
have been here since they were very
young are to all intents and purposes
British and that's what government is
not not quite ready to wrap its head
around yet but but it needs to because
the people that will be most affected by
some of these deportations and British
kids that stand to lose a parent
British partners that stand to lose a
partner more than a hundred and fifty
members of parliament wrote to the
government saying the flight should be
postponed until recommendations from a
review into the Windrush scandal
published now the Home Office insists
there's no Windrush link with these
deportations but one of the leaked
recommendations from that review is that
in foreign national offenders who spent
most of their lives in the UK should not
face automatic deportation the flight
came after an angry debate in the House
of Commons on Monday as opposition MPs
demanded a rethink despite protests
inside Parliament and outside Downing
Street the UK government says it will
continue to deport foreigners who are
serious persistent offenders campaigners
say that's not what's happening and
they're determined to keep up their
legal challenges Nadine Barber al
Jazeera London